Speaker 1: A couple of people in the audience
have notified me about Marjorie Taylor Greene 2.0.
OK. This is a woman named Michele Fiore, who
is running for the governorship of Nevada.
And quite frankly, Marjorie Taylor Greene 2.0
seems like a pretty good way to describe her
article in the Las Vegas Review-Journal embroiled
in controversies. Michele Fiore announces a
run for governor. Las Vegas Councilwoman
Michele Fiore said Tuesday she will seek
the Republican nomination for governor, casting
herself as a champion for conservative values
amid a cascade of controversies that figure
to be election cycle targets. We're going
to talk about those in a moment. But she is
under FBI investigation for campaign finance.
She's been accused of breaking a fellow council
woman's finger in an assault in City Hall.
And more, so we're going to get to that in a
moment. Here is the Michelle Fiore campaign ad.
It involves trucks. It involves guns. And yes,
I think Marjorie Taylor Greene 2.0 is a great
nickname for Michele Fiore.
Speaker 5:
I'm Michele Fiore, and I'm running for governor.
I spent my whole life fighting the establishment.
I was the first female majority leader
in Nevada Assembly and one of the first
elected to endorse Donald J. Trump. You
better believe I was attacked for it.
Speaker 1: Imagine as a badge of honor bragging
that you endorsed Trump before most other
people like as if that's something good.
Speaker 5: Washington Post called me a gun
toting calendar girl. And Politico Magazine
since I was the lady Trump and I don't care.
We need outsiders, fighters.
Not the same old, boring,
moderate compromise blue blazer politicians.
Speaker 1: By the way, if you're only if
you're only listening. When she said the same
moderate politicians, she pushed over a TV that
had an image of Mitt Romney on it, which which
again shows you the political alignment that's
happening within the Republican Party right now.
Speaker 5: Let's start with a three shot plan. Oh,
God. Vaccine mandate to ban critical
race theory and stop voter fraud.
The Joe Biden administration is coming
Speaker 1: after we now understand that,
you know, she says, ban vaccine mandates, OK,
ban critical race theory, by which I suppose she
means ban the teaching of critical race theory,
meaning that the governor decides what's taught
in school rather than teachers and educators. And
then she says, we're going to stop voter fraud.
As governor of Nevada. You have no involvement
in elections in any state other than Nevada,
and Nevada is not even one of the places where
it's been seriously. Now that it's been serious
anywhere, but whether they've really gone out
of their way to allege that voter fraud took
place in 2020, there was a little bit of
it. But really, the states were Michigan,
Pennsylvania, Georgia, Arizona. So as governor
of Nevada, what do you even have to do with
voter fraud? It's all crazy.
Speaker 5: I'm Michele Fiore,
and I'm ready for the fight.
Speaker 1: OK. So she is in the middle of
a number of different problems. The in December
of 2014, it was reported that the IRS filed
dozens of tax liens totaling a million dollars
against her and her home health care business.
Billions against the businesses involved
unpaid employee payroll taxes. Nice,
huh? She said. I am 100 percent in compliance
and blamed her ex-husband. She's dealt with the
voiding of her home health care license. There's
an FBI investigation. This is a very beleaguered
individual. Also in the days after the storming
of the US Capitol on January 6th. She attended the
Republican National Committee's winter meeting on
Amelia Island, Florida, where she said to the New
York Times, I surely embrace President Trump. So
a number of different problems and controversies
for Michele Fiore. She is running for the governor
of Nevada and I think Marjorie Taylor, she seems
in some ways even wackier than Marjorie
Taylor Greene. Something about the video
makes her seem even more unhinged. But maybe
somebody that we're going to get to know.
By the way, I also want to mention November 2nd in
Virginia. There's a gubernatorial election, just
because we're talking about gubernatorial stuff.
If you live in Virginia, make sure you're voting
on November 2nd. I plan to cover the results of
that race live. I think it will be interesting. As
Bill Sherry told us yesterday, he said, You know,
the results of the gubernatorial race in Virginia
could impact Joe Manchin's willingness to do A or
B when it comes to spending infrastructure, etc.
So that'll be an impactful and meaningful race in
Virginia. November 2nd is the date. Is that right?
I hope I'm yes. November 2nd. So we're going
to be streaming live the results on that night.